[Music]
foreign
so in the last lecture we introduced how
to approximate derivatives of a function
f with respect to t d f d t using these
finite difference derivatives so instead
of taking the limit as delta T goes to
zero in the normal definition of a
derivative for lots of reasons if we
want to compute this on data or we want
to compute this for a function but on a
computer we often drop the limit as
delta T goes to zero and instead use
this approximation for a finite but
small delta T
and so we cooked up a few different
schemes that will all approximate this
first derivative DF DT
and we saw how the error of those
different approximations behave based on
these Taylor series expansions of f of t
plus Delta t f of T minus delta T and so
on and so forth so when you plug these
Taylor series into these approximations
you find that your forward and backwards
difference schemes have error that is on
the order kind of the leading error term
is on the order of delta T and the
central difference scheme is more
accurate so its error is on the order of
Delta t squared so if I want better
accuracy of these methods I have to make
delta T smaller but if I make delta T 10
times smaller these methods only get 10
times more accurate whereas Central
difference gets a hundred times more
accurate so pretty cool okay
um and so you can actually uh cook up
even higher order accurate schemes so
you could cook up an order delta T to
the fourth or sixth or fifth or third or
whatever your heart desires
so I would um you know we use these
Taylor series expansions so I'm just
going to point out that you can actually
come up with a higher order accurate
approximation for dfdt using more terms
instead of just F of t plus delta T and
F of T minus delta T you could add F of
t plus 2 delta T
and F of T minus 2 delta T
and you'd go through the whole kind of
expansion dot dot dot you know I'm not
going to write it out here and so this
is actually a great homework for you so
this is a homework I would assign my
students in my class is what you can do
is write out this Taylor series
expansion for f of t plus two delta T
and F of T minus 2 delta T
and then see just like what we did in
central difference is we tried to
isolate this F Prime of T the thing we
wanted DF DT while killing as many terms
in the Taylor series as possible above
it so we wanted to you know kind of push
our error out as far as possible and as
high of a power of delta T as possible
and so with these two terms this was as
good as we could do that's as many terms
as we could we basically killed these
second derivative terms and our error
kind of came out into this um delta T
cubed F triple prime term so when we
divided by delta T we got an order Delta
t squared error term
what I claim is that if you expand these
Taylor series in pink here
with those four equations you'll be able
to get an expression kind of a a central
difference but with four points instead
of two points you'll be able to cancel
not only these terms but you'll also be
able to cancel more terms in your Taylor
series and I claim you'll be able to
push this error to an even higher power
of delta T so that's a really good
exercise try to use these terms here to
cook up an even higher order accurate
Central difference scheme using all four
of these terms to push this this delta T
I think you'll be able to get it
probably to delta T to the fourth power
that's my guess I'm not 100 sure I
haven't done this in a while it'll
definitely be higher than Delta t
squared
similarly you could build a higher order
finite difference with a with only
forward terms so you could only use f of
t f of t plus delta T and F of t plus
two delta T and again you could you
could use just those three terms and
come up with something that's order
Delta t squared
same with backwards difference you could
use only F of t f of T minus delta T and
F of T minus 2 delta T and cancel out
terms in your Taylor series to get
something that's ordered Delta t squared
so that's an excellent homework set for
you you'll get really good at both you
know expanding the Taylor series
manipulating these terms and you'll
really understand what this error
accuracy means okay so so highly
recommended to do that
um
you can also approximate the second
derivatives so maybe I'll do that right
now so I think what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to show you how to do the
same thing but for computing the second
derivative D Squared F DT squared by
using finite differences and then we're
going to talk about how to approximate
these on actual data vectors so in the
last video I showed you how to do this
with if you actually had access to this
function f if it was like a real
analytic function like sine or cosine
but now I'm going to show you how to do
this if someone you know emails you a
data set how do you compute the
derivative or if you're measuring the
path of a comet or an asteroid in time
how do you take the derivative of that
position in time for example when I
don't have access to F of t plus delta T
that's the future I don't know the
future so I only have these past
measurements how do I do that okay so
that's all coming up in this lecture
um good and
so maybe I'll just start with the second
derivative and I'll start with the
definition so the definition of the
second derivative uh so second
derivative
second derivative
is uh D Squared f
d t squared and again we could write
this as the limit
um
as delta T goes to zero of my first
derivative F Prime
evaluated at t plus delta T minus my
first derivative at T
divided by delta T and you could take
that limit as delta T goes to zero and
then this would be the honest to
goodness second derivative but again as
we did here you could drop this limit
and just take this finite difference to
approximate DF D Squared F DT the second
derivative
and so you could
you could apply
a
promise
and plug in t plus delta T to that
approximation and you can approximate F
Prime at T again using those schemes and
plug so but I would recommend if you if
you use one of these approximations for
f Prime at t plus delta T and F Prime at
T
try using the same scheme to begin with
so you know you could use the forward
difference pink scheme for f Prime of t
plus delta T and the forward difference
pink scheme for f Prime at T and if you
plug that in you'll get kind of a
forward difference approximation for the
second derivative of f with respect to T
and so that's actually another good
exercise is you know like try this
approximation for f Prime and then see
what the error approximation is see if
it works try the same thing for backward
difference try the same thing for
Central difference
try a different scheme for for this F
Prime and a different scheme for this F
Prime and I don't think it's going to
work as well it might not work at all
okay but that's not what I'm going to do
right now
we're actually going to construct an
approximation of this D Squared F DT
squared just like we did before by
trying to take some combination of this
these two Taylor series so that we
isolate the term we want and kill as
many of the other terms as possible okay
so what we want to do is we want to
isolate this F double Prime of t f
double Prime literally means D Squared f
d t we want to isolate this
and we want to kill as many terms in the
Taylor series as possible
so the first thing I'm going to do is
it's pretty obvious that if I add these
together if I add star and double star
equations if I add F of t plus delta T
and F of T minus delta T I'm going to
cancel out all of the odd powers of T
because all of the odd powers of T are
going to have a minus sign so I'm going
to cancel out the F primes and the F
triple primes which seems like a really
good start
and I'm going to be left with my f
double primes and 2 F of t
so if I write down uh just bear with me
f of t plus delta T
plus so here we subtracted them here
we're going to add them F of T minus
delta T
that's going to equal 2 F of t
which I don't want this is just
something I don't want
plus two of the terms I do want plus uh
two times this thing which 2 factorial
is 2 and 2 over 2 is 1. so this is Delta
t squared
F double Prime of T that's the thing I
want
all my cubes are going to cancel
so I'm going to get something you know
that's plus order delta T to the fourth
and higher right my cubes cancel out so
I'm only left with my my fourth order
delta T to the four F quadruple prime
those terms are going to add up and then
I'm only going to have every even term
the order t to the fourth t to the sixth
t to the eight and so on and so forth so
this is actually a really good start
again this is the thing I want
so if I take this expression
minus 2 F of t
divided by t squared Delta t squared
I've isolated F double Prime so that
that's what I'm going to write down now
is I'm going to write down uh maybe I'll
do this in pink
I'll write down a second derivative
and this is a central difference second
derivative scheme my second derivative D
Squared f d t squared is approximately
equal okay again I'm just going to walk
through this this expression here if I
subtract 2 F of T and I divide by Delta
t squared I've isolated the thing I want
so this is
F of t plus delta T
minus 2 F of t
Plus
two at no not two just a single one just
one f
sorry
Plus
F of T minus delta T
and I've rearranged that when I
subtracted this 2 F of T I just put it
in the middle here because I kind of
want to order them this is the Future
Point this is the present point and this
is the past point so future present past
I just kind of order them in time but
it's the same as this minus 2 F of t
and then I divide by Delta t squared all
of this
divided by Delta t squared and that
isolates my f double Prime so that's all
equal to F double prime plus my order
delta T to the fourth divided by Delta t
squared so that becomes order Delta t
squared
so plus order
Delta t squared and so again the SEC the
second derivative
Central difference
this is Central difference because the
point I want F of T is sandwiched
between F of t plus delta T and T minus
delta T so this is literally called the
central difference I approximate the
derivative in the center by you know the
points away from it so it's in the
center of these two points that I'm
using the central difference second
derivative approximation gives order
Delta t squared error so the error so
the thing I want
is f double Prime
of T and then all of this is the error
term
and so when I divide by my Delta t
squared this error term becomes order
Delta t squared delta T to the fourth
divided by Delta t squared is Delta t
squared so really easy again we can
construct uh first derivatives using
different schemes with different error
accuracy we can construct second
derivatives with different schemes in
different uh order accuracy I could
create a fourth order
Central difference second derivative D
Squared f d t squared again using these
four points not just these green points
but these pink points as well okay and
sometimes this is called a a stencil
because if you literally look at
um you know let's say we're looking at
this
[Music]
um
this curve that we're trying to take the
derivative of like this and we have you
know these points here
let's say this is T and then each point
to the right is t plus Delta t t plus 2
delta T T minus delta T T minus 2 delta
T I'll just draw you know t plus delta T
and T minus delta T and of course this
is 2 delta T minus 2 delta T and so on
and so forth if I have data these points
you know
these discrete delta T measurements in
time
then essentially
you can almost think of you know this
second derivative is
one of these
plus one of these minus two of these so
you know one of the f plus F of t plus
delta T plus one of the F of T minus
delta T minus two of f of T is going to
all the Taylor shares is going to cancel
out and I'm going to get my the thing I
want with the second derivative of f
with respect to t plus a little bit of
order Delta t squared error and so uh
these points here you can almost think
of it like a stencil like when you're a
kid and you make a stencil and you trace
out a stencil you know you use these
three data points in this very
particular way and you take that
combination and you get this derivative
and there are higher order stencils that
use more points that go beyond so if I
want a fourth order scheme I'm going to
need to include these points in my
stencil and I'll get some combination
like this but now it'll have F of t plus
two delta T is an F of T minus two Delta
T's and it'll be higher order it'll be
order delta T to the fourth so really
good exercise for you to do is to really
just try to do all of these you can make
you know almost any of these that your
your heart desires you can make higher
order Central difference forward
difference backwards difference first
derivative second derivative third
derivative and you just need to use
these Taylor series in the right
combination
so really cool stuff
good
um
that's mainly what I want to show you
for the first half of this video I think
for the second half what I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you
um how do you actually compute these
things on real finite discrete data sets
so again in the past we we assumed this
is a very small kind of subtle
distinction but in the past lecture we
assumed we had access to an actual
function and we can evaluate that
function at any point in time we like
and so we you know evaluated sine at t
plus delta T minus sine of t
but let's say I actually just have a big
Vector of data someone emails me a
spreadsheet or a list of measurements or
maybe even better yet I'm collecting
measurements in time I have you know my
telescope and I'm measuring the position
of a planet or a moon in time and I just
have the measurements I have I'm
collecting them in real time and I want
to be approximating these derivatives in
real time okay so I can't just query F
at any time I like I'm getting
measurements of F at these very discrete
punctate times t t plus Delta t t plus
two delta T and so on and so forth how
do you compute this on actual data so
that's what I'm going to gonna show you
now
um
and I always like to think about this
you know why wouldn't I always use a
central difference scheme right it's
obviously better than my forward and
backwards different scheme it is better
accuracy scaling in delta T So Central
difference has order Delta t squared
accuracy which means if I cut delta T if
I make delta T 10 times smaller
these only get 10 times more accurate
but this one gets 100 times more
accurate so why wouldn't I always use
this scheme and at least one reason is
because you know if I'm measuring
something with a telescope maybe I'm
measuring you know maybe there's a
ballistic missile coming uh you know
from one part of the world to another
part of the world and I want to compute
its derivative and its acceleration and
things like that it's velocity and
acceleration I don't know what F of t
plus delta T is this is a measurement in
the future so if I'm Computing these in
real time I don't actually have access
to these t plus Delta T's I only have
access
uh to T T minus delta T maybe T minus 2
delta T so if I'm doing real-time you
know calculations of something that's
evolving in time I'm actually kind of
stuck with backwards difference
derivatives okay so that's one reason
why I might not use the better second
order Central difference scheme another
reason might be maybe again I actually
do have access to all of those points in
time maybe it's historical data and
someone just emailed me this data but
still at the beginning and at the end of
those time points at time zero and at
time final at Time Zero there is no F of
T minus delta T so I can't do a
backwards difference or a central
difference at my starting time
I have to use a forward difference at
the left time point at the t0 and
similarly at my final terminal time
point I don't have t plus delta T so I
can't do a central difference or a
forward difference I can only do a
backwards difference at my final time
and so if you have historical data you
know from some start time to some end
time
essentially you can do central
difference in the middle but on the left
you have to do forward difference and on
the rightmost point you have to do
backwards difference so these are real
practical considerations you have to
keep in mind when you're doing this on
data okay
so good
um I'm going to probably erase this draw
a little picture of what I mean by data
and then we're going to code this up in
Python and Matlab all right so just one
moment
okay so now I'm going to show you how to
do this numerical differentiation on a
data set I erased everything because I
figured you probably can remember
forward difference backward different
Central difference and if not pause the
video try to write them down for memory
try to make sense that these are
actually what they should be and then
you can kind of rewind and see if they
match and if not you might want to you
know kind of re-watch that section
but here what we're going to be doing
I'm just going to draw a nice big
picture of the function that we're
taking the derivative of okay f
and it looks
like at least in my notes I switched
from F of t a function of time to some
function of space f of x I hope at this
point you feel comfortable enough that
like the specific variables don't matter
this could be a function of time and I
could take its derivative with respect
to time this could be a function of
space and I could take its derivative
with respect to space it doesn't matter
so everything I showed you with f of T
also applies to f of x you can take DF
DX using exactly the same methods if you
have some position X of T you could take
DX DT in exactly the same way I showed
you before okay so I want you to get
kind of sometimes I switch variables
because I wasn't paying attention and I
forgot and I maybe I got lazy sometimes
I switch variables on purpose because I
want you to have that power of
abstraction and that flexibility that
you know it doesn't matter if I'm taking
DX DT or dfdx or dfdt sometimes my
function varies with respect to time
sometimes my function varies with
respect to
X and sometimes my function is going to
be called X and it varies with respect
to T and in any of those cases I can
take I can take the derivative of my
function with respect to its independent
variable using the methods we've talked
about
so we have some function uh I'll pick
some cool colors here if I can do it so
I've got
um
I've got some function and what we're
going to to do is we are going to Define
this function on discrete data points
we're going to have
X1
X2
X3 and I'll just draw a few X4
dot dot dot
um
you know all the way up to let's say x
Big N in case I've got n data points
here and I'm going to assume that these
are spread apart
Delta X apart they don't have to be
Delta X apart they could actually
technically be unevenly spaced I'll talk
about that at the end but for now assume
that each of these is spaced at a fixed
Delta X if this was a function of T
these would be a fixed delta T this
would be the Delta T's from before and I
literally have measurements of my
function I've got F at X1 I have F at X2
F at X3 F at x4 at X5 dot dot dot all
the way up to my function evaluated at
FN
and so I'm literally going to call these
points
F1 F2 F3 F4 dot dot dot up to f
n okay and if you like you can say well
you know F K is equal to my function f
evaluated at x k at the K location k
equals four k equals five and so on
which is equal in this case to F of
K Delta X okay I'm assuming that this
starts it you know zero and this is
Delta x 2 Delta x 3 Delta x 4 Delta X
and so on and so forth so this is uh
just just setting up some notation here
that I have my data points X and I sorry
I have my x positions where my data was
taken and then f is my actual data
and so I essentially have two vectors I
have and I'm going to have my math over
here so I have two vectors I have X1 X2
X3 dot dot dot to x n
that's a vector of initial positions
where my data is is measured and then I
have the data the vector of the data
itself which is my function evaluated at
X1 my function evaluated at X2 evaluated
at X3
and these could be you know measurements
from a telescope or from radar or from
anything that I'm measuring in space you
know or in time or whatever it doesn't
really matter
and so the idea here like I said is that
if this is a data set someone you know
emailed me or I downloaded a software or
I'm collecting this data set
I can compute the derivative DF DX okay
I can compute dfdx
the F DX
and I can use for example a forward
difference at this leftmost point
because I don't have
I don't have a point to the left of F1
that's my first point so I can't do
central difference or backward
difference I have to do forward
difference at F1
so I'm going to do you know forward
difference at X1
similarly at the rightmost point I have
to use backward difference because I
don't have a point past this right most
point I can't do central difference or
forward different so I have to use
backward difference
at x n and I can use Central difference
you know in the middle
so I'm just writing this down to be very
very complete this is what I'm going to
do I'm literally going to code up you
know a scheme that does these
derivatives to approximate the
derivative of F and it's not going to be
on a function f it's on this data Vector
F I'm literally going to take F3 minus
F2 divided by Delta X to get my
derivative at that point and so on and
so forth okay so I'm going to
approximate my derivative at each of
these points by taking the difference of
these numbers now these are not
functions these are numbers data numbers
I'm going to take the difference of F3
minus F2 divided by Delta X that's going
to give me my forward difference
derivative at f2 for example okay a
pretty simple idea but again I want you
to feel really comfortable going back
and forth from functions to data data is
is a big deal
and just before I go into Python and
Matlab
I'll point out there's actually some
really cool new machine learning results
so we compute these derivatives all the
time when we numerically simulate
physics and the real world so if I want
to numerically simulate a drum membrane
or a fluid flow or a guitar string or
pretty much any physical system that
varies you know in space or in time or
in both I'm going to be in a computer
kind of evaluating numerically
derivatives and setting them equal to
stuff and solving for other variables
I'm going to be using these numerical
derivatives in a computer
and oftentimes researchers for example
in fluid mechanics if you want to solve
uh for the turbulent flow over a wing
this is a very expensive calculation and
researchers will cook up very high order
accurate numerical schemes to
approximate that better and better and
better with you know small Delta X's
they want as good of an accuracy as
possible or with small Delta T's
and so interestingly researchers have
recently within the last few years
cooked up new finite difference
derivative schemes kind of new stencils
if you like of how to use this data to
approximate the derivatives at these
points even better
tailored to specific problems like
turbulence or like shock formation in
fluid flows using machine learning so
there's some really cool papers there is
a pnas paper
I think bars and I and other co-authors
I'll put a link in the um you know in
the description if I remember and if not
give me a comment to remind me but
basically they learned with machine
learning they took like really really
accurate data and then they learned from
that data what is a really good stencil
that four turbulence for example
approximates those derivatives
especially well or for shock formation
it's a really cool idea kind of going
Beyond this Taylor series classical math
I really like that idea okay good let's
code this up let's try this out I think
we're ready to go and then that'll be
the end of the video
okay good
so I'm gonna go over let's see which
one's up first looks like we got python
so
um again this is code uh written by Alan
Captain aglu based on the Matlab version
of this code from before so this is very
very similar to the code from the
previous lecture in fact you know the
previous lecture the code was lecture 14
finite difference this is the finite
difference too I'm very creative with my
naming scheme and so similarly we're
going to compute the the the finite
derivative finite difference derivative
of of sine of x but we're not going to
do it from uh the function sine of x
we're basically going to create a vector
of data
and then we're going to take the
derivative of that Vector of data okay
so
um here we're going to basically assume
we have n equals 30 data points so n is
30 and we're going to create this kind
of spacing
uh with I guess a spacing of something
like 0.1
Delta X is going to be 0.1 so Delta X is
0.1 and we're going to go up to 30 data
points and we're going to evaluate that
Vector of X on sine of sine of x so this
is going to return a vector of f values
for sine of x
so we're going to plot
um you know the the true function f the
clean function then we're going to plot
the data these are these x's and I'm
inverting my color so these are not red
X's the inverse of red is cyan so if
this looks confusing because this should
be red and it's not red it's because I'm
inverting my color scheme uh because I'm
sticking with the black background here
and so literally what we're doing is
we're Computing this
derivative with these these Blue Points
here so these blue points are our
function evaluated at those discrete X
points
and so as we mentioned before
we
um you know we we have to do forward
difference at the X1 location at the
first location and you know uh python
starts its indexing at zero so it's if
it's again uh anyone who knows python is
not going to be confused by this
starting at zero this is the leftmost
point here and at that leftmost point I
can't do central difference I can't do
backwards difference I have to do
forwards difference so this is the
forward difference and remember this is
not sine of X Plus Delta x minus sine of
x it's literally f
the second F minus the first F divided
by Delta X okay that's the forward
difference
and then in the middle for you know I in
the range of of the middle I can do
central difference that's F at the next
Point minus F at the previous Point
divided by 2 Delta X that Central
difference and then at the rightmost
point the nth point
and again in Python uh index minus one
is the last entry of this this array so
DF DX at the last point is going to have
to use a backwards difference because I
don't have the next forward point so
it's the last Point minus the second to
last Point divided by Delta X really
easy okay just a big for Loop and it's
going to compute all of this stuff and
notice I didn't even put in Delta X here
we literally did just for all of the you
know F1 minus F 0 we did the
corresponding X1 minus x0 so we didn't
even use Delta X or two Delta X we
actually took the difference of the X
data so this code technically would work
even if my X was not uniformly spaced
and this would be really cool I'd really
like you to actually try
to convince yourselves that even if this
x data is not uniformly spaced if it's
not Delta X apart but the the spacing
changes this is still going to be an
accurate approximation scheme and you
can convince yourself by trying to plug
in the Taylor series there's any number
of ways you can convince yourself of
this you could basically try to
approximate you could zoom into a little
region a little region
where let's I'm going to try to draw
this so that these are totally different
Delta X's
so you know this is uh x k
x k Plus 1.
and x k minus one but I'm assuming that
these are not a constant Delta X apart
you can still go through all of that
Taylor series
um
you know expansion algebra and convince
yourself that you know four different
Central difference and backward
different still scale with these Delta
X's for for these these differences you
can still approximate the derivatives
using these schemes even if my Delta X's
are not a constant that would be a
really cool exercise for you to do
good and actually something I would
really appreciate if any of you in the
the audience would like to type up a
little list of you know the questions
the homework questions I've asked you
for this lecture and like pop it into a
comment I will very likely pin that
comment to the top so that everybody can
see like here's the homework problems
for for this lecture that would be super
useful for me
now I'm just going to plot everything
and if we plot things we will find
that the true derivative which we're
pretty sure is going to be like a cosine
function right because derivative of
sine is cosine so this is the the cosine
derivative and then the computed
derivative again in these these should
be red X's but I've inverted it so
they're cyanxes these are the
approximated finite difference
derivatives and they're all quite
accurate because I had a pretty small
Delta X my Delta X was like 0.1 and so
all of these are going to be going to be
pretty small okay uh so this is really
cool you actually get a really good
approximation and it's especially good
in the middle because we're using
Central difference but it's not terrible
at the endpoints
it's actually better at the endpoints
than I think it should be and I think
there's a really interesting reason why
and I hope I don't botch this but if we
remember the forward difference and
backward difference have an error
the error was something like D Squared f
d x squared times Delta X
okay that was the error for forward
difference and backwards difference and
so
the D Squared F DX squared does actually
matter like in regions that have high
curvature high D Squared DX squared I
will get more error than other regions
but notice my function was sine of X and
the second derivative of sine of x is
sine of X and so at the forward
and at the first data point and the last
data point of my of my numerical data
this is 0 and this is pi approximately
and sine zero and sine Pi is very close
to zero well it is zero the sine of zero
and sine of Pi is zero and so at these
end points where my error should be
higher because I'm using forward
difference and backwards difference at
these endpoints it turns out that my
curvature my f double Prime is actually
really really small there and so that's
why even though I'm using a less
accurate scheme at the left point and at
the right point they still look really
good because they're multiplied by this
really really small number
and if you look closely I mean I'm not
going to zoom in here but if you look
closely I would assume that even for
these Central difference points the
error is going to be a little higher
here because this D Squared D D Squared
FDX squared is larger here
than out here because sine is larger at
Pi halves than at zero or Pi so just
kind of a cool property like you really
can get a lot of information from these
Taylor series this is really really neat
okay that's actually what I wanted to
show you you could play around with this
code you can download this try different
Delta X's try a course grid try a fine
grid and you'll actually see I mean I
guess I can run this for a course grid
let's see uh let's try not to to mess
this up
I guess I would make this coarser by
changing this to 30 over 2 so that's
only 15.
but let's make it 10. let's make it 10
data points so instead of 30 I'm going
to have it be 10 data points it should
be way less accurate because it's a way
bigger Delta X
let's run that let's now plot my data oh
it's super
ugly gross data here
uh and now when I plot this
well Central difference is still pretty
darn good but now I'm getting a little
more error on my endpoints because of my
my forward difference I'm getting a
little more error notice this actually
started at 0.1 and this ended at three
so it's not exactly zero and Pi so this
term is not exactly zero and there is
some noticeable error there okay
kind of cool so you can try this for
bigger delta T Delta X smaller Delta X
try you know you could try a different a
second order for a difference at the
left hand and a second order backwards
difference in the right hand you could
try all kinds of things okay I'm going
to switch to Matlab
so we
are this numerical differentiation
scheme on these data vectors uh you know
X and F and so it's pretty easy to do
this in Matlab like Matlab is built for
you know these kind of Matrix
calculations so I'm going to create a
vector from point one to three it's
almost zero to Pi it's a proc it's close
to zero to Pi but not exactly and we're
going to compute the derivative of sine
of x but instead of like the last
lecture where I evaluated sine of X Plus
Delta X like analytically here we're
just going to take a big Vector of X
we're going to plug it into this
function f and we're going to have a
vector of data out so X and F are
literally these vectors of data that
I've I've drawn here
uh so I'm going to plot you know x f by
X and um and the data so let's just do
that real quick
so this is kind of the the function and
the data I'm using so all of these blue
dots are are these values that so it's a
pretty you can see it's a pretty fine
Delta X it's a pretty small spacing so
this is probably going to be pretty
accurate and even though this looks like
a parabola this is just you know one
hump of a sine function from from
approximately zero to Pi
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to compute all of these these
derivatives but again on my leftmost
data point I'm going to use a forward
difference derivative so that's this one
here dfdx at the leftmost point at index
1 is you know F F2 minus F1 divided by
Delta X
all the points in the middle for 2 to
end minus 1 my derivative at a middle
point is going to be the central
difference you know K plus I plus 1
minus I minus 1 divided by 2 Delta X and
then at my rightmost point a DF DX at
the nth index it's going to be that last
Point minus the previous Point divided
by Delta X that's the backwards
difference scheme okay and notice I'm
not actually using Delta X here I'm not
actually using Delta X I'm actually
using X2 minus X1 and x k plus 1 minus x
k minus 1 and I'm actually using the
difference in x
I'm not Computing a constant Delta X I'm
Delta X could actually change in the way
I've written this I could actually have
non-uniformly spaced data X and this
will still run and this will still give
me good approximations of my derivatives
this is actually a really good thing for
you to check is that
if I have irregularly spaced X data
that's not constant Delta X's apart but
there are irregular spacings of the
Delta X these are still going to be good
schemes and these will still work and
approximate my derivatives I can still
approximate my derivative
uh you know by the slopes of these
various lines between these various
points using this and they'll have
basically the same error properties uh
based on the Taylor series so that would
be really good for you to convince
yourself that this also works for
non-uniformly spaced data okay so I've
computed all of that now I'm going to
plot it and that's pretty easy to do
and let's see uh I'm gonna make this X's
for my data just like I did before
and I'm going to make them very large
just like I did before
good so now the white curve is the like
analytical derivative the cosine
function and these blue X's are my uh
finite difference numerical
approximation again at the left and at
the right those are using forward and
backwards difference and all the points
in the middle are using Central
difference you might expect the points
on the the end to be more inaccurate to
have more error which is almost
certainly true because these are only
Delta X accurate whereas Central
difference is Delta x squared
interesting fact the error of the
forward difference and backwards
difference is not just proportional to
Delta X it's also proportional to the
second derivative of f with respect to X
and the second derivative of sine is
also sine that's minus sign and at
approximately zero and approximately Pi
sine is very small so here the error is
actually going to be smaller for forward
difference and backwards difference than
in the middle so kind of a cool fact
that's interesting okay
the central difference
its error is going to be Delta x squared
times the third derivative of F and the
third derivative is cosine which is also
going to be small in the middle so it's
actually going to be more accurate in
the middle than at the at the endpoints
interesting stuff you can get from from
these Taylor series but I really just
wanted to show you here how easy it is
to compute these derivatives
really comfortable
with Computing these finite difference
derivatives for for functions so you can
if you have data or if you have a
function you can approximate the
derivative the second derivative the
third derivative using you know only
forward points or only backwards points
or you know points on either side and
you can get different order accuracy for
all of those schemes so again we'll use
this later when we talk about you know
numerically integrating a differential
equation DX DT equals f of x for example
you know if this is DX DT then we could
approximate that as you know x t plus
delta T minus X of T over delta T equals
f of x at T
and I could rearrange all of this and
get an update rule X at my next time
step is equal to exit my current time
step plus delta T times my function
evaluated at X at my current time step
so this is you know all based on
information I have now and this is my
state in the future
so you can basically step your system
forward into the future one time step
then once you have that you can plug
that in here and you can step It Forward
another time step and plug that in and
Step It Forward another time step and we
will basically be able to develop a
numerical integrator so that if we have
a differential equation we'll be able to
integrate our trajectory through that
differential equation
at Time Zero time one time two time
three we'll be able to numerically
predict what the system will behave like
so for example if I have a pendulum I'll
be able to start with an initial
condition and predict the future I'll be
able to numerically integrate the the
pendulum you know swings back and forth
using a numerical scheme like this so
that's actually probably coming up in
two lectures is really taking everything
we've learned here and applying it to
numerical different numerical
integration of ordinary differential
equations
all right thank you
[Music]